You know how sometimes you get the wrong sent to your house from someone else?
Well, that happened. I got sent the wrong thing.
I hate when I get the someone else's mail, dude. Guess what? I have a thing.
If, if, uh, if you get my mail at your house,
that's your mail. That's your mail. Now, if it's a gift,
you're welcome. If it's a bill, pay that. Okay. That's how we do it.
The postal service works the way it works.
And if you mail something somewhere else, that's the end of it. Dude.
That's what's happened to every single time.
I've gotten a jury duty letter.
Never saw it. I mean, I don't even know if I've gotten it.
I don't even know if they know I exist the court because every time
the post office has sent me
jury duty,
I guess it's been lost because I've never seen
one. All right.
It's not that I've gotten it, seen it and thought, Oh, I'm not going
because I'm a good guy. It's that?
I've never gotten a jury duty notice. And that's the truth.
I'll put my hand on the, on the Bible.
And I'll say that to a police officer.
All right. Shall I hope that person goes to the,
be the juror for me? All right.
I hope that person sits in the juror's box for me and goes like this guilty,
not guilty. I listen.
Dude. Imagine me in a jury box. I swear to God, first of all,
they would never pick me. They'd be like.
So have you ever had any run ins with the law?
And I'd be like, Oh, well I hope I know, but I can't wait. Well, you know,
one time I they'd be like, you know, what were your two guns blazing? All right.
You're out.
And it'd be like, well, the,
why the I have to wake up at 6:00 AM and get here by nine dude. I'm out.
In a rip t-shirt.
You didn't even wear the right attire. Why don't want to be here, man?
What the?
Me? And then they got to get a juror, jury, jury duty for me.
And it's the guy that got my.
Oh, so this is the guy. This is.
The guy I got the mail from. Um, so yeah, dude,
if you get, Oh man. And if I was ever selected in,
in any of the realm of possibility of, okay. Yeah.
We'd like to pick Mr. Uh Dalea.
I would be in the jury box. I dude,
I would roll my eyes so much that it would be allow I do it so hard
that it.
Would be loud.
You'd hear me. You you'd be like, okay.
And so they'd be like doing the cross-examination. So you're saying Mr. Plumber,
that when you were in the parking lot, there were trees in the way.
That's what you mean.
We're saying between, uh,
the so-called victim and yourself and the guy would be like,
that's what I'm saying. And then you hear me in the back. Just be like, Oh,
come on, dude. Like really? Come on, sir.
What do they even do? Have a juror acts up. Did they stop it? All right.
All right. Well, he's being a Dick.
That would be me from the germs box.
And everyone here knows it because we talk about it behind them.
When we take a recess,
we talk about it in the jury room or whatever the it's called back there behind
you judge. We talk about it. And even the Baylor shot me.
A bailiff shot me a look, look, bailiff, or the female.
What do you call a female bailiff. Bailiff at the Baylor fat gave me a look.
So you do the math, but I don't think he did it.
Can I get it like a pizza or something? I'm so hungry.
You guys make meat at the wrong times.
Dude. Why lunch? Lunch at 1130. Really?
I eat at 10 30, three 39.
And 1:00 AM. And you make me up my whole schedule, dude,
because some guys stole a [inaudible] some money from a gas station anyway. Um,
so I, Oh yeah, if you get my mail,
that's it. If it's a gift, it's yours. If you, if it's a bill,
pay that. Okay.
Now I get mail. Most of the time it's mine.
Sometimes I get mail and it's someone else's and
dude, I don't give it back to the person that mine. Okay.
If it's something like, okay, wow, this person really needs to get it. Okay.
I'll I'll Uber send it to somebody. But dude,
even if it's seven houses over, like I got to walk down here. Now they up.
That's the game, dude. The mail is mine now. Okay.
Thanks for these, you know, shorts or whatever the people mail each other.
Guess what? I got, dude, I got cookies.
I got cookies. I got cookies from a friend to another friend.
And they showed up on my, on my thing.
Not only was it the wrong mail because I know the name by the way, dude.
I'm not going to tell. I'm not going to tell you who it was,
but it was a huge celebrity.
And they got their cookies from a friend that was giving them cookies for
a nice, Hey, you know, just thinking of you
On, I got it on my doorstep. It had the huge celebrities name on way,
bigger than me dude. And, and, and it,
and it wasn't delivered to the wrong place.
It was delivered to the right place because they had my address on it.
So you up cookie maker. So guess, guess what, dude, I ate the cookies.
I ate the cookies, ate that big celebrities cookies.
There were so many of them and I ate them all.
Sometimes I ate half of them and ate another half and was watching the Sopranos.
And I threw away the rest of the two because honestly, because I forgot,
I had them after three weeks and they're a little bit stale, but I ate them,
do it and I didn't give them back.
And that celebrity is not going to get those cookies. Okay.
Cause that's the game, dude. That's the game. If you miss,
if you send cookies to the wrong, uh, my, my girl, she's like,
we're going to make scones now for the person.
So now we've got to give scones to the celebrity.
I got to show up, imagine the celebrity, not knowing.
Just also imagine the other person, like what the we told my dad about it.
And he was like, yeah, you don't do that. He was like, well,
what kind of guy did I raise? And I was like a cookie eater.
I'll tell you that much, dude, the mail.
So I ate the cookies and they were pretty good. And thank you. Um,
I'll have to find out who sent it. I, I, um, I still have the note.
It was a beautiful note. I read it. I read the note and I,
and I ate the cookies and uh, they're mine and it's fine.
And it's going to be fine.
And that person who sent the cookies would probably like,
I wonder if that celebrity got the cookies and that person has no idea
that the cookies, if we can, did you ever get my cookie that you know,
that I'm sure that didn't happen yet because it's not,
it hasn't been long enough. Uh, and they have no idea that crystally,
the comedian sat in his living room, watching the Sopranos,
eating those red velvet cookies, man,
there were red velvet cookies and I ate them dude.
And there were also a cookie called the beer cookie and there was also a cookie
called the cupcake cookie.
And there's also a cookie called the chocolate chip cookie.
And there was also a gluten-free cookie. And I was like, yeah, right, dude,
the am I Mormon? I'm not in a boot and free chocolate chip cookie
was a cookie crate was what they're called. And thanks cookie.
Great. Anyway, dude. Well,
I got to make scones for the sorry, Hillary Duff, who was Hillary Duff
ate Hillary Duff's cookies.
I know her too, which is like,
I did a movie with her and I see her in my neighborhood sometimes. Hey,
Hillary does cookies do it. And she has no idea.
She has zero idea that those cookies are even percent to our probably,
or maybe she does. And she's like,
where's my cookies and crystally a Hillary Duff cookies.
And I got to make her scones or some.
She also gave me other things do it.
Hillary diff she dropped off like eco-friendly dish soap and stuff.
And it was like so sweet and diapers and eco-friendly diapers.
And she was like here and I was like, Oh, thanks. And then her.
I got her cookies and I ate them dude like a real piece of.
If you ever get my that's the game.
No, my dad was like, Oh, now you know what?
Karma is going to come back around and that's going to bite you in the.
And I said, dude, this is the end of the karma.
This is karma getting her back for some or the cookie maker. I'm sitting pretty,
dude. I'm a good guy. I ate those cookies. Cause it was my karmic duty.
Yeah, dude. I figured it out. Wow.
I'm scot-free dude. I'm the cookie monster dude.
I'm I'm the cookie monster dude. I ain't Hillary Duff's cookies. Jeremy Renner.
Take me out.
Yeah, dude. Red velvet sensation. Chocolate chip cookies,
birthday cake cookies. Gluten-free cookie.
That was chocolate chip cookie.
But also the other one that I mentioned earlier that I forget. Yeah,
they were all
[inaudible] take me out, dude.
I ate them. Dude. I ate them and I went no more. The cookies went district.
The cookies went that way, dude. It was like sparks flying.
When a guy's in a montage of a movie making something dude rat me out.
[inaudible] I figured it out, dude.
That's karma coming back around. Don't do bad. You won't get it.
I can cook. Eaton
changed the shot of the camera.
[Inaudible] dude, we lose our minds man.
Guess why this isn't eaten because I ate the cookies instead. God Jen renter.
Take me out. [inaudible] hell yeah,
dude.